I've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p caller
raises an interesting question yesterday
we talked about the congressman Michael
Grimm former congressman who was sent to
prison is now out of prison and he wants
to go back to being a congressman and
here's a voicemail sort of related to
that you're talking about this guy who
just got out of prison for tax evasion I
was just thinking I was interesting how
people is on the prison can go back in
the office but at the same time but a
person can vote I just wanted to know
your thoughts on that thank ya I've
actually talked about this before the
entire convicted felons can't vote thing
if we believe as a society that you
commit a crime and in order to repay
that debt to society you go to prison
once you get out of prison presumably
your debt has been paid and you should
be fully reinstated as a member of
society which includes voting rights I
think that there is a case to be made
and there's a by the way this is not
uncontroversial there's an easier case
to make that while you are in prison you
should not be allowed to vote I'm not
saying I'm taking that position but that
case is stronger to me once you've paid
your debt to society I don't understand
the rationale for saying you still
cannot vote because once you're released
it's because you've on paper made good
for the crime that you committed so I
think that's interesting it is easier to
get back into politics after being in
prison or jail than it is to vote and
that's probably something that relates
to our priorities that we have to
rethink on today's bonus show Tom Petty
dead at 66 years old we will talk about
that we will talk about the Nobel Prize
winning Americans who have done some
interesting research on circadian
rhythms very interesting and we will
also delve a little bit into the
background that's been uncovered of Las
Vegas shooter Steven paddock gambling
someone who was a pilot just very
unusual and sort of sporadic bits of his
history but still nothing approximating
what we would sort
colloquially think of as a motive for
what is now known as and was the
deadliest mass shooting in American
history so you can get access to the
bonus show and heroes talk about all of
those stories by signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership there's a
coupon code available it's I voted 17
you can also get access to the bonus
show and the commercial free broadcast
show by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show where
contribution start at just a single
dollar a month
check it out pick your poison and then
we will talk to you on the bonus show